dans le sud de la saskatchewan les
éclaircies sont de plus en plus rares le
secteur énergétique en arrachent
et avec lui à peu près tout le monde
avec les mois qui passe on pourrait
penser que la morosité amène un vent de
mécontentement à l'endroit d'un
gouvernement et son premier ministre
mais pas ici
il est celui qu'il nous faut on peut
compter sur lui répondent bien des gens
de la place
ils se préoccupent de la saskatchewan le
long des autoroutes tout est fait pour
rappeler que l'homme est la solution
pour que la saskatchewan demeure forte
que jamais vraiment eu de je dirais de
baisse de popularité significatif bras
droit bon p'tit gars de shawinigan alors
que le mouvement conservateur est en
pleine période de reconstruction au pays
ici le contraste est frappant après plus
de huit ans au pouvoir brad wall est
toujours bien en selle et rien ne semble
ébranler l'appui envers le doyen des
premiers ministres
partout où il passe surtout en pleine
campagne électorale et se présente comme
celui qui se bat pour sa province
un combattant peut-être mais vu la
saskatchewan brown donne pas
nécessairement l'image de dieu c'est un
premier skate à droite mais qui essaie
d'être relativement modérée sur ces
centristes style populiste l'extrême
vu de l'extérieur c'est une autre
histoire
mais quand il sort de sa province pour
aller la défendre ailleurs au pays bas
là il fait pas dans la subtilité et ils
sont des ennemis aussi ailleurs au pays
et non en faisait neuf en quelques mots
ou en quelques caractères sur les
réseaux sociaux
le ton est souvent provocateurs 26000
lutte contre les changements climatiques
bombardier et surtout énergie est ottawa
québec et le maire denis coderre sont
dans sa mire la cmm et contre le projet
énergie est se défend de tenir un
discours anti québec mais juste à temps
pour la campagne électorale en habile
politicien prague on l'a su peser sur
les bons boutons un thème canalise la
frustration de la population
la péréquation s'impose maintenant en
trame de fond
c'est vrai que le québec c'est une cible
assez facile surtout que le québec
historiquement très bon sens comme c'est
une province qui reçoit aussi les
péréquations alors brad wall c'est aussi
de faire des amalgames et et je pense
que il a il a réussi à détourner un peu
l'attention des électeurs qui sont
préoccupés par la situation économique
leur dire en fait le danger ça vient de
l'est et le québec et d'autres provinces
aussi
là où les temps sont plus difficiles et
les rhji est est perçue comme la clé
pour ouvrir d'autres marchés et voilà
que la péréquation que reçoit le québec
grâce au pétrole de l'ouest fait
désormais partie du discours populaire
en freinant énergie est le québec est
très égoïste lance-t-il bon orateur
brown sait faire vibrer les cordes
sensibles mais c'est ainsi qu'au fil des
ans il a su se donner un profil
nationale est une question s'impose
naturellement beauty lui succéder à
stephen harper qui va tirer sa révérence
il faut partir à un moment donné une
promesse durant le prochain mandat mais
quand exactement
si le fait rapidement mais là ça veut
dire près de la course à la direction du
parti conservateur fédéral vraiment
intéresse les rumeurs ne date pas d'hier
alimentée notamment par ceux ci j'essaie
seulement de faire trébucher
l'opposition officielle
ici ça remonte à près de deux ans il
part en pleine campagne électorale
votre français comment est-il moment où
il sollicite un troisième mandat
brown prononce un serment d'allégeance à
sa province
on n'est pas intéressé jusqu'à temps
qu'on soit intéressé en attendant la
suite
et pour la première fois depuis qu'il
est aux commandes brad wall doit faire
face à une autre réalité économique
le boom est terminée les revenus sont en
chute
les déficits pointe à l'horizon faire
briller la province s'annonce plus
difficile